foreign
hey dudes hi welcome to Tuesday welcome
back to another episode of honest
trailers commentary
um Spenny is out but that's okay that's
okay you got me and with us as always
Islan
um hello Lon hey how's it going I'm so
glad you jumped in and started hosting I
know we briefly discussed this yesterday
but then we did not clarify this morning
so I was like not even I hope she starts
because I don't know what to say well I
hope that I mean I you know I hope that
my smiley face was enough to communicate
um for those of you who have not been
here before this is on his trailer
commentary is where we talk about the
honest trailer that went up today that
was The Goonies um so we're gonna go
through we're gonna watch it with y'all
we're gonna do some starting and
stopping with some of our commentary on
some of the jokes that are happening uh
we're gonna play some deleted scenes and
uh we will end with some questions and
comments from viewers just like you uh
before you put it in the thing yes I
broke my arm no it's not a good story
moving on to The Goonies
um I just want to give that out of the
way don't put it in there it's not a
good or fun story it's just dumb and I'm
old and I broke my arm and I'm having
surgery tomorrow
um so lawn what did you think of the
Goonies I know it's been probably a
while since any of us have seen it yeah
I this was one I was in the right age
range so I really like this as a kid and
what I realized going back as an adult
and re-watching which I've done a few
times this was not my first time going
back since childhood maybe my second or
third what I realized as an adult is all
the positive memories I have from this
movie are really from that last like
half hour there's like a good there's
like 30 minutes towards the end where
they really get going on the adventure
they're in the cab or they're on the
pirate ship all this stuff is very like
produce these huge cool sets and it's
very like amblin and almost all I think
the one thing I loved as a kid that
isn't from that last segment is Corey
Feldman uh pretending to order Italian
food I used to do that bit as a kid
they're like we wanted to be a
scallopies
I used to like that everything else I
like is like they start playing the
pirate organ and all right and I think
that's what everybody remembers and you
forget that there's like 80 minutes of
shtick leading into that that is like
not my favorite now going back yeah it
is so so sticky and
um the movie kind of I what I what I
appreciate about it is that it does just
kind of get going like as soon as it
starts that movie is going and it
doesn't really give you a chance to
really catch your breath but because of
that it also assumes that you know
things that you don't know like it
assumes that you kind of know
um a lot about these kids and like their
relationships to each other and you
learn a lot about it about it too
but it makes a lot of assumptions for
it's like hey we just got to get there
we got to get to the adventure and it's
like okay cool adventure and then 80
minutes of like you said just just stick
and just like silliness because how long
do they spend in the house before they
even find the treasure map it's it's a
long segment in the house and then you
know you get them they're on they're on
their way and you've got all the stuff
on the bikes and that stuff I think is
mostly fine but then I think the real
problem point is from when they get to
the fratellis and they think it's a
restaurant and they go inside and then
they're kind of wandering around in the
back of this restaurant this is when we
meet sloth this is when we get to the
fratellis it's very long and it takes a
very long time for them to get from the
restaurant to the part right under the
restaurant to the caves that go under
the town to finally
getting into really like one-eyed
Willy's Cavern that they really have a
space to explore and it becomes a real
adventure and I feel like there it gets
very bogged down with them doing a lot
of like they've given and I I don't
think I want to make it clear that I
don't think it's these kids the kids are
great like all the kid actors in This
fantastic most of them went on to become
more famous One we'll talk about that
yeah yeah just won an Oscar but
but uh I think the kids are all great
but they've given them like Abbott and
Costello like full Vaudeville routines
and it's like so much to give the kids
who are like 13 14 these very young
actors and I feel like that's their
Chris Columbus was not doing these kids
anything right and yeah and I enjoyed it
but it definitely is we'll talk about
this uh uh it's one of those that I
definitely was looking at it through
Nostalgia covered glasses
um but you know what so let's just go
ahead and get into it um let's go ahead
and start The Goonies on Australia
[Music]
in a world where every new release is
about small town kids on bikes having a
spooky Adventure in the 80s experience
the original film about small 10 kids
and bikes having a spooky Adventure in
the 80s that proves the actual decade
may not have been full of neon but it
was full of non-stop bullying do the
Truffle Shuffle
[Music]
those were the days epic voice guy the
best years of your life
we all love the 80s right
The Goonies experience
uh one thing give you a little behind
the scenes context there was some debate
uh among the honest team were we gonna
get pushback on E.T really kind of set
the the stage et's the classic amblin
kids on bikes there's a reason why it's
the emblem logo right uh uh and so this
is not really the original this was
already kind of marketing back to E.T in
some ways I feel like close enough right
and when it's the same team when you're
riffing on yourself yeah and I mean I
think like today when you watch like
stranger things and they're they're
referencing that Vibe E.T and The
Goonies are the two the first two places
you go right right
yeah absolutely 100 great yeah yeah and
let's keep going the cult classic and
that it works best when you're young and
impressionable as you journey to
America's hairy armpit the Pacific
Northwest a location where you never
have to change the camera settings
because everything is always gray there
you watch five Future movie stars and
also these two pull off the most
um so one thing we do want to mention
also obviously um congratulations
that's dope and amazing
um
and that's exactly what I was gonna say
okay no no no no no that's great we do
make the joke about like and those two
but uh the the guy who plays junk uh
junk
um that could have been a nickname in
this movie um the guy who plays Chunk um
uh Joel Cohen am I correct
um I think it's something like that is
uh he is an entertainment lawyer Jeff
Cohen Jeff Cohen thank you he is now an
entertainment lawyer and he's been a big
time entertainment lawyer for decades
and he was actually the person who
negotiated for kihui Quan to be able to
be in everything everywhere all at once
um which was part of why he uh key
thanked him in his Oscar speech um and
also because goonies never say that blah
blah blah but yes so while we do make a
joke about that we do also recognize
that dude is doing big things and
honestly probably has the most stable of
all Hollywood careers for being brutal
yeah I mean look it's not like Corey
Feldman lighting Hollywood on fire at
the moment he just went on to do a lot
of stuff posting Goonies that was really
cool yeah that's really what it is all
right get done plan to stop
gentrification find some buried pirate
treasure
Meet The Goonies a group of Misfit
outcasts who deal non-stop verbal abuse
to each other
you shut up about that stuff shut up
shut up data shut up shut up mouth shut
up mouth shut up yeah at least I have a
brain so stupid Mouse
shut up maybe the risk but Outcast
because they're all little just a
thought Mikey is their leader
um she really put some stank on that uh
shut up at the last time
is mean in this movie like and it's not
even a like there isn't really a like
today if you if you wrote the beginning
of the movie where they're all bullying
each other and they're all very mean by
the end there would be like a Redemption
Arc where they all realize that they're
true friends
not not The Goonies no and the Clinton
ends the movie just as mean as she was
at the very beginning
right this isn't the one where they
suddenly become found family even with
the people that they can't stand they do
it's a very good it's just a throwback
kind of thing where it's it's got that
like New Yorker East Coast Vibe where
it's yes yes I'm going to constantly
tell you I hate you but we understand
that there's mutual love and respect at
the foundation of me constantly telling
you how much I hate you which is funny
because this is uh that is so not West
Coast Pacific Northwest culture uh
Pacific Northwest culture is way more uh
uh sarcastic and passive aggressive it
would be like these these kids are
aggressive aggressive there would be way
more passive aggression if this was
actually on the Oregon coast for sure
yeah
um there's something refreshing about
that it just if this movie just takes
place at like a brutally mean cruel
world and like we don't Hollywood movies
don't especially for younger people yeah
it's like not like that anymore like
it's a so it the world is not usually
this vicious without there being some
sort of like but at the end they realize
like that you know it's all love right
and this town like everyone's terrible
and all of these kids are pretty awful
when you start learning things because
it's like oh man you're making chunk do
the Truffle Shuffle fat shaming was cool
back then but we don't like it now and
then later when the cop is listing off
all of the many ways that chunk has
committed crimes and lied and conned
people and then when chunk is admitting
to all of his other also terrible things
that he has done to people I mean no one
deserves a truffle shuffle but that kid
does deserve a swirly they're all
they're all bad it's a you know yeah
everybody's kind of and I and I like
that I'm I I don't want to be misquoted
like I enjoy that they don't do a
Redemption there's nothing at the end to
let you know that it changed the happy
ending is they get to stay friends and
keep their houses not that they've
learned anything from this experience no
I fully expect that one of them is gonna
do like uh like one of those the good
son where like they find an overpass and
like dump a fake dead body over it like
I fully expect that's what they're going
to start doing as soon as they turn 16
and get their driver's licenses
crew today they're bad kids
near the ocean's 11. all right let's
keep going and Keeper of the goonie code
Never Say Die cooties always make
mistakes data does machines
[Music]
mouth is cool but rude but no wait chunk
can be a party dude Kenny Mississippi
mud and they got chocolate eruption all
right you know what that means pause
real quick
uh so I just want to give credit one was
the one who pointed this out and wrote
uh and wrote the lyrics for this let's
go ahead and spontaneously realizing
that The Goonies map onto the Turtle
character types I had no choice but to
rewrite with you all right let's Jam the
F out
[Music]
he's gotta save their homes
when it
and there we go beautiful beautiful
um who gosh I cannot remember his name I
wish I wrote it down
just killing it lately this he also did
uh the uh the song in Velma
um just nailing nailing these these song
parodies so uh shout out to him this one
was great this came out really good I
love that it can be just like a half
note oh I never get away with it like
it's it's very obvious what song We're
riffing on here but
you're gonna get away with it and I love
that for us and for you all right let's
keep going evil Deboer and his nepo baby
plot to repossess their homes The
Goonies will head off on an adventure
after these comedy bits
dozens of Comedy bits
I got it
I guess not cool
and while they never say die they do say
Rich stuff a lot for some reason our
last chance to see if there really is
any Rich stuff stuff is near the
restaurant maybe there's some rich stuff
one-eyed Willy's Rich stuff the last guy
who went looking for the wood stuff oh
my good stuff did you eat there is stuff
all that rich come on Treasure kids it's
treasure
stop making Rich stuff happen Goonies
Rich stuff is not gonna happen I
remembered like that was the thing I
knew at the beginning I was like I'm
gonna keep track I know that they they
say Rich stuff all the time that'll be a
funny joke but I had no idea it was so
much like I thought it was maybe two or
three times it's like
we got some there's like 15 Rich stuff
quotes in the goodie it's a lot yeah I
mean you could you say treasure uh you
can say gold you can say money and I
guess kids do like you know friend
groups make up their own slang or
whatever but Rich it just doesn't it
never lands right to me it always feels
like an old like an adult screenwriter
came up with it and put it in the mouths
of babes yes no this is definitely
someone who's like this is what the red
the kids say stuff yeah there's really
Mikey and mouth on their own started
saying Rich stuff like it's it's weird
yeah it's very awkward uh keep going you
tag along as they explore the hidden
tunnels under their town and discover
the dark secret it hides below I'm sorry
what'd you say I say when they run into
the skull that's when it gets good like
that's when the sets get more elaborate
you could tell like the the technical
like the comedy sort of is like okay
we're we're done with the comedy we're
ready for the adventure yeah that's when
all the memorable the water slide and
the pirate ship and the pirate organ
that makes the ground fall away all the
peppers shoes yeah all the Temple of
Doom memorable bits are from there and
there's a long time where they're just
kind of in some tunnels that's like oh
okay let's get through yeah let's get
through the wet tunnels
a lot of wet tunnels uh let's go
Plumbing work
no
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like a magical Flint Michigan this
is supposed to be water it's wet in it
standing in their way are the fratellis
a familiar so Italian they make a
Roberto benini sounded like Chris a
pratt
you're close to the television said you
just screw up your ammo they're
criminals
Catholics and opera singers
so you might think of course they also
run an Italian restaurant
but that would just be perpetuating a
crude Italian stereotype
pepperoni
no way Mamma Mia
that was the first time I had ever seen
Joey pants oh yeah I think for most of
us yeah yeah this was almost definitely
my intro to both Robert Dobby and uh and
Joe's pants yeah for sure yes they're
giving it 110 they're not like not
bringing it because it's a dumb part in
a kids movie like they're going for it
but wow the material for them is like
just about everybody is like pretty
stereotyped in this we were joking about
that because uh I I said like I think in
one of our one of the group chats or
slacks or something uh I was like you
know it's funny because data keeps
calling himself data like in the third
person like he's trying to make that
nickname stick and then we think about
the other nicknames people have and
we're like uh he probably that's
probably a smart idea yeah
nickname his his like he
there's something kind of like
racialized about his whole character
like he's presented as kind of talking
in this sort of pigeon English weird way
and you kind of think it's just an
application for him but then you meet
his parents and they also are like that
it's like oh it's just it's just a crude
Asian it's just the 80s yeah yeah
it's not great Marge Simpson noises keep
going the film everyone remembers Sports
incredible pirate ship set spielbergian
mix of humor and horror and one of Cindy
loper's greatest Bops
while overlooking how it takes forever
before anything fun happens nothing
exciting ever happens around here anyway
is chocked full of product placement
what Plus
they spent a hundred thousand dollars in
80s money for that Baby Ruth product
placement
yeah that is wild you could tell it's
like very like their whole they're
lavishly holding the rapper up to camera
a bunch of times I mean I guess in a
post ET World they realize the value of
these kinds of if you integrate the
product into the story like well yeah
well no but Baby Ruth didn't pay for
them to do it they paid Baby Ruth
really I know that's what I said because
I went to look it up to see how much
money that they and this is I mean I got
off Wikipedia so you know grain of salt
no that's probably true I just that's
weird you would think that's what I
thought I used to because I wanted to
make a joke about how this was one of
like you know the first uh instances of
you know being paid for for that and I
was gonna bring it back to the reseason
I looked it up and I was like well that
joke doesn't work at all now
yeah no they paid uh they paid you could
just make up your own candy bars this is
what I'm saying they have them just
sitting around it's like you know if
they have like everybody on TV drinks
the same brand of fake beer like you
could have just done that but I guess
they were really for that authenticity
poker face that's the only show I can
recall recently where she just drinks
she drinks exclusively real beers on
poker face if you ever see Charlie on
Poker Face she's got like a Coors Light
or like a Miller High Life they only
average really it must be some kind of
product it must be either that or they
they know exactly what we associate with
Miller High Life because I know that I
do the champagne of beers
let's keep going
and relies on a cheap wing to the
director's other superhero films for the
big emotional payoff
but despite its flaws recapture that
magical feeling of what it's like to be
a little kid again still full of wonder
a sense of possibility and just really
loud and annoying
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
shut up I'm old now
truer words were never spoken um so much
of the dialogue in this movie is just
kids yelling over other kids
like it sounds it reminds me of like
when your friend first gets a podcast
and doesn't realize that everyone has to
take a turn to talk and everyone's just
like talking over each other like if
only they were talking about like you
know alpha males and uh high-value
females then we wouldn't know that they
were uh they were doing that but yeah
it's definitely and so much of the
screaming and falling and talking over
each other and getting wet is like 80 of
this movie maybe 90. it's that comedy
beat of they're all so loud and so
excited that they all end up talking
over each other they they go back to
that sort of well a lot as like that way
of suggesting like this is what life is
like when you're a goonie it's just
constant chaos and excitement and it's
like at a certain point it is kind of
like uh enough already we we get it
they're very they're very loud they talk
over each other all the time yeah like
please please please stop yelling our
stereos are better than yours we're back
then yeah I can my neighbors can hear
everything
all right I think uh let's go ahead and
I think this is the last little bit
starring
potatoes bro country for young men the
Hollywood shuffler stand by mean Oregon
Jones and the Temple of goon Don't Tell
Mom the babysitter almost died you have
to save Martha Wario and Waluigi Throw
Mama down the drain and me when I think
of a new Little Pond for the end of
these videos
[Music]
[Applause]
the goondock Saints a chat do be blowing
up you're gonna live with me now dude
he's a person not a puppy he didn't just
get a new friend get your parents a full
grown ass man to feed
yeah you can't just take home an adult
no you I mean
with at some point the state's gonna
have to get involved it's like it's on
some level it's this guy's been abused
there's paperwork to be filled out here
there's definitely paperwork uh well hey
uh thanks so much for hanging out we've
got some more stuff coming but this is
the part of the show where we thank you
for sticking with us uh make sure you
subscribe to our Channel we've got some
more videos every single weekday hit
that like hit that Bell uh just for us
and for you so you don't miss any of our
uh our funny funny uh fun nonsense movie
stuff
um it's for us but it's also for you
we're looking it's also for you yeah we
want to make sure that you never miss
any of us see we're very kind that way
we're magnanimous all right and I
believe that we have got some outtakes
starring the puffer Brothers Bob Newby
The Hobbit an Unexpected Journey keep
rolling rolling rolling rolling bandana
of brothers let's go Brandon young
Thanos nacho Seaway the cry guys The
Burbs begins license took a knife the
exhaust boys quad for the money the
kissing youth raising no varsity snooze
small time moves and nice wreck
[Music]
[Applause]
irrational treasure
sneaks and Geeks tiny goon Adventures
goon Willy hunting
we got really excited yeah
all right so I think that's it so now we
are going to uh go into our chat let's
look at some questions here I haven't
even looked at them yet look at me I am
not I really like the I really like nice
Shrek I'm sad that didn't get it isn't
it yeah I like that one it's kind of
like a swamp oh we have more objects
says William thank you let's do it
Rosalita is better than me because after
everything Mount put her through I would
have definitely kept those diamonds
she's running over like here don't sign
the paperwork don't sign the paperwork
it's like um excuse me I'm retiring I
worked over like one day too she's very
she's very dedicated considering it was
like they literally the mom brings her
by that morning like this is Rosalina
she's gonna help us out and at the end
she's like no I'm gonna sit the house
your family's rescued like you have no
stakes in this and they're supposed to
move like the next day and they just
start packing and she's supposed to do
all this work
I don't like it all right let's go to uh
Evan J presser asks uh recycling a
question that was not used a while ago
should Juan take over for Ford and
Indiana Jones I think it would be great
baffled it hasn't happened uh fans of
dig it I
I mean I think it would be fun I think I
mean he's shown he's got the action
chops uh I would dig it I would be super
into it
um I mean I think it's more likely to
happen now that he's got an Oscar I
could see why people want maybe talking
about it like five years ago but I could
see why people will be talking about it
now I don't I don't know uh obviously
I'm not you know I'm not against I'm not
against it sure like I would go see it
if there were short rounds yeah these
now but like I put on this I don't I
don't feel like we need to keep humping
in the especially with no more for we
know this is it for Ford in D4 they're
so tied together short rounds that
character is great but like a foil for
Indiana Jones I I feel like give give
give uh give tihui Kwan his own
franchise like he's a he could he could
sustain his own thing he doesn't need to
be short he doesn't need to play the one
part he did in the 80s forever he's yes
free to be a new character I like
exactly let him be more guys like that
yeah I'd I'd hardcore
um and then
oh uh let's see let's go to Wayward mine
says if you had to cast some of the road
rules for a Goonies reboot Who Would You
cast ignoring gender
oh okay well they're kid it's tough
because I don't really like what have I
watched with today's youths you know
like I don't know actors that age
because we already know it would just be
all of like the stranger things kids the
kids that they they're too old now yeah
that's true you can't be Goonies anymore
that's what I'm saying like the kids who
would be the Goonies now are like
they're on Nickelodeon shows I don't
know thankfully you'd be weirded out if
I was rattling them up
why is lon watching this much Disney
Channel
um yeah I would assume it would be like
a like yeah the the kids coming up from
the Disney's or the Nickelodeons exactly
I mean that's for you to audition and
you know like you you'd cast I've
discovered someone yeah here's what you
would do today obviously the fratellis
are gonna be Stars you know you're gonna
get you're gonna get Helen Mirren to be
Mama Fratelli or whatever
sexy mama Fratelli yeah I mean should
feel like she's your first she's your
first call if you're doing an Ann Ramsey
party today
[Music]
um
anyway those the any adult but I also
feel like you give them one there's got
to be one like Mr Walsh instead of just
hearing that he told Mikey about
One-Eyed Willy yes
in the movie and he's someone we know
Liam Neeson or somebody and he's the one
who like tells the kids about One-Eyed
Willy in the beginning so that we get
that connection and then you get another
celebrity in there probably also
flashbacks where you get a famous person
to play One-Eyed Willy and uh oh yeah
for sure yeah oh that sounds good the
vision of him at the end or something
you know but like you would you would at
least do a flashback where it's like
Russell Crowe was one I really yeah all
right well one more uh and then we will
give you your clue for next week
um Adam Holbert this is a question for
you Lon are you saying Goonies was
actually a red notice this entire time
[Music]
I almost submitted before I saw that
someone put in a rational treasure I
almost named it Regional treasure okay
yeah
note that there's no there's no fancy
parties
yeah no there aren't it's not it doesn't
really ever take on a heist Caper it
doesn't have any of those so I would go
it's kind of just missing a strict
definition of a red nose but does it
does have the combination of like sticky
one-liner constant banter with like a
crew on on a wacky adventure and like a
little bit of action a little bit of
Comedy a little bit of Adventure like
like I could see why people would be
asking it's it's sort of red notice
adjacent red notices Jason love it love
it love it all right so we are going to
go ahead and take off before we do your
clue for next week
um you know uh just make sure uh these
days it's it's so uh there's so much
going on you got to keep your third eye
open all right there you go just keep
keep your third eye open it's a
documentary about the band Third Eye
Blind
that is what we're doing that's all we
do here thank you so much thank you Lon
uh for hanging out thank all of you for
hanging out with us and we will be back
and see you next Tuesday have a good one
bye
[Music]